this video will highlight how to monitor
student progress with assignment reports
on Khan Academy
the assignment score report is a tool
for teachers to view and analyze their
students performance on assigned tasks
start by selecting the class from your
teacher dashboard and then selecting
scores under the assignments tab in the
left side navigation menu
this will bring you to the assignment
scores report if the assignment is a
video or article and students have
completed the assignment you will see a
green check mark
to earn completion for a video the
student must have watched at least 90
percent of the video at no faster than
double speed
to earn completion for an article the
student must have clicked into the
article
if the assignment is an exercise quiz or
test the student's best score will be
shown in a color-coded box
the boxes appear as read for scores 0-59
yellow for scores 60 to 99
or green for a score of 100.
if the student has not completed the
assignment the Box will remain Gray
to access a more detailed report for an
individual assignment from the
assignment scores report select the
assignment name for any assignment that
contains questions
this report is called the response
report this screen shows you an example
of an assignments report for an exercise
on the left hand side of the screen you
can select the first or last attempt
students made to answer the question
you are also able to select each
question to see students responses
if you've chosen to provide different
questions for each student the questions
appear in the order students found them
most challenging
the question students answered
incorrectly most frequently appears at
the top while the questions students
answered correctly most frequently
appears at the bottom
if you've chosen to provide the same
question for all students the questions
appear in the order in which they were
presented to them
on the right side you can select a
specific student or the whole class to
view the assignment responses report
select the responses tab on the right to
see a summary of student responses
correct responses can be highlighted by
selecting the reveal answer button you
can view which students gave which
Answers by selecting an individual
response to display student names
we recommend keeping students name
private when sharing this report with
the entire class
Additionally you can select the draw tab
to reveal a scratch pod space that you
can also use to solve problems live with
students
consider using this report to do error
analysis with your students analyze
where mistakes were made that led to an
incorrect answer incorrect
misunderstandings
we also suggest having a student solve
the problem step by step for the class
instead of the teacher as a way to
encourage student voice and build
students confidence
in the hits tab you can view the
step-by-step process to solve the
problem
these are the same steps provided to
students in real time when they select
get a hit option in an exercise
you can also access the assignment
responses report by selecting the manage
tab from the class dashboard and then
selecting the blue hyperlink that says
responses for the individual assignment
the assignment score report and the
assignments responses report are helpful
in monitoring assignment progress for an
entire class
if you would like to look more closely
at the assignment progress for a single
student use the individual Student
Assignment report
from The Clash dashboard select activity
overview from the left side navigation
then select the individual student whose
assignment progress you want to view by
selecting the blue circle next to the
student's name
this brings you to the individual
student report
select the assignments tab to view all
assignments given to that student
this report displays the due date and
time assignment name assignment status
attempts made on the assignment and the
student's best score if the assignment
is an exercise quiz or test
foreign
[Music]